- [Interviewer] All right, Kevin.
Kevin, where'd you grow up?
Where you from originally?
- I grew up in South Los Angeles area.
In the neighborhood of Crips.
Around the Crips.
- [Interviewer] Were
you in gangs as a kid?
- I started gangbanging
around the age of 12.
- [Interviewer] 12?
And tell me about your family.
You grew up with both your parents?
- Yes I have both my parents in my life.
I'm the middle child.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- Actually I grew up in
a well tooken care of family actually.
Like I said, I'm the middle child.
I have a older brother
and a younger sister.
You know as a middle child,
you know, I feel neglected.
Which is probably not true.
I just felt that way.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
Yeah, it happens.
- You know it took me
towards other routes.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, gangs?
- Yeah, exactly, gangs.
You know bad behavior. Should I say.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Have
you don't prison time?
- I have done no prison time.
In and out of county jail.
No prison time yet.
Hopefully I don't.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I'm not trying to do that.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you?
- I'm 30.
- [Interviewer] You're 30?
- I just turned 30.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have kids of your own?
- No kids.
- [Interviewer] No kids?
- [Interviewer] So tell me about your life
after you joined a gang.
What went on there?
- Actually let's take it
back right before then.
I actually was on a right path, you know?
Good grades. I made the honor roll.
You know one of the top
students in my class.
Until, who you hang with is who you are.
That's the motto that's actually true.
You know I hung with certain
kids in the neighborhood
and I got used to that lifestyle.
And it took me to take a bullet
to understand that life is real.
- [Interviewer] So you got shot?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- At the age of 14.
- [Interviewer] 14?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Where were you shot?
- I was shot twice in the leg.
Twice in the left leg.
That's one time.
And I got other times I was hit also.
When I was 16 I was also hit
in the back and in the leg.
- [Interviewer] And the
scars on your thigh.
Did you show it?
- Yeah I got scars.
This was when I was 14--
- [Interviewer] 14?
- That was the first time I
received a couple of them.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You call this the tibia?
- And--
- [Interviewer] Did it break your bone?
- It shattered the bone actually.
- [Interviewer] Oh wow.
- And the bone exposed to the air,
which caused me to have what
they call osteomyelitis.
Which is a bone infection.
Osteo means bone.
Myelitis means infection.
And during the time of my bone infection,
I was prescribed norco.
And the first time I ever took a norco,
that first norco, that first pill,
I told myself, "Wow, I love this shit,
"and I'm addicted." I swear to god.
I tell you the first time I felt that,
when it kicked in and I felt that high
I said, "This is a high like no other."
And ever since then I
been chasing that high.
And it progresses from norco
to actually starting Vicodin,
to norco to Percocet,
Percocets to oxycodone without
the Tylenol inside the pill.
oxycodone, it's just straight dope.
And what got me really on it
was the street value of
oxycodone 30 milligrams
in South Los Angeles.
Street value was from $15 to $20 a pill.
And that's if you single out a pill.
And wholesale price $10, $12.
But anyway, I was able to get my hands
and get that pill for a dollar.
So it was very affordable for me.
So every day I will pop the
30 milligram oxycodones,
and it got to the point where
I wake up in the morning
and I pop 10 at a time.
And that was just to get
me started through the day.
You know around 12 o'clock, mid noon,
shit I'm getting high
again off the motha fuckas.
I'm taking another eight.
By the time it's night times,
when I was getting ready to close the day,
another eight, nine, maybe even 10.
Throughout the whole day, man,
I already popped about 50 goddamn pills.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah, and it was very affordable for me
because, like I told you, I
was getting it for a dollar.
And the street value of
it is from $15 to $20.
So you can imagine me
able to get my hands on
that pill for one dollar.
You go crazy.
You go nuts.
So once I lost that
value, that dollar value,
I started experiencing withdrawals.
And being sick, dope sick,
I never though I experience,
I never thought I would get to that point.
I never thought that it'd happen.
But it happens.
And you rather fucking be dean, man.
You'd rather be dead
than feel that feeling,
that dope feeling, man.
So when I felt that dope sick,
I knew what opiates is,
and I knew that heroin is an opiate.
And I knew that it is
actually also affordable.
So by me knowing that
I knew about Skid Row,
downtown Los Angeles.
I decided to take a trip down here,
and the first person I encountered, man,
I ask, "Where the dope? Where the heroin?"
The first person I encountered he had it.
I took that dope,
went home all by myself, with nobody.
Nobody got me on this.
I went to the house,
and believe it or not,
we got these Android phone,
I went to YouTube,
and I'm trying to see how
the hell I'ma do this drug.
You know I got it,
how in the fuck do I get
high off of this shit?
So first thing I read
was, chase the dragon.
You chase the dragon is
you put it on the foil,
make a little, what they call a, tooter.
It's like a straw.
And you put a flame under that foil.
Right on top is the heroin.
And it burns and melts.
And as it melts a cloud of smoke come,
and you chase it with the straw.
I didn't go quite a good job on that one.
I didn't get high.
I was wasting the dope.
I figured I would do that.
So I bought more dope.
When I bought the dope
I bought quite a ...
I spent about a hundred dollars on it
'cause I knew that I would
be fucking up (laughs).
I knew I'd be fucking
up on trying to do it.
So chasing the dragon just wasn't me.
I immediately put that to the side.
The second what the said,
take a Visine bottle,
empty out that Visine bottle,
rinse it out,
and you put your little
dope inside, put some water,
shake it up, let it melt.
And now you got it to
where you could snort it.
- [Interviewer] Hm.
- Didn't like that high.
It fixed me, it fixed me.
I no longer was dope sick.
But I didn't like that high.
And I was trying my hardest
to stay away from that needle, man,
but I didn't like those two options.
And I got a grandmother
who was a diabetic,
man, I already had needles in the house.
They was already in the house.
So I got on YouTube,
"How in the hell do I bang this?
"How do I slam this?"
They told me I could use a spoon,
or this metal top, which
is they call a cooker.
Tell me how much water to use.
Told me to put cotton to filter out,
you can use cotton from a cigarette butt,
or a Q-tip, some kind of
cotton to filter out that dope.
So you won't, you know, draw up the cut
when all the bad particles
that come along with the dope.
You try to get as much as purity
out of the dope as you could.
That's what that cotton is for.
So anyway, I'm on YouTube.
Step-by-step, just figure
out how can I slam this.
I was successful.
Got it all into the tube.
I got my syringe, I got about 60 units,
or 60ccs of dope inside of this syringe.
Now I'm trying to find a vein.
Now here it is,
I'm in and out the hospital before this,
like I told you, I done been shot.
Having that bone infection.
All kind of shit happening to me.
So I pretty much kind of
know how to get that vein
from watching the nurses
and the doctors give me.
Bam, hit first try.
Man, that blood shot up in (mumbles).
It shot right up in that syringe, man.
And here I go (air release) pushed it.
10 seconds, five seconds,
10 seconds, they had a rush.
It's a rush, man, like no other.
I swear to god to you.
That rush was a hundred times way more,
way more powerful, and way more better
than that first norco I told you I took.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah, no shit.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- I knew it was ...
I fucked up. (laughs)
I knew I wasn't going back to pills.
That first time I banged it,
I knew I was not gonna
take another pill again.
But I thought to myself,
I took so many pills
I thought I had fucked up my kidneys,
so I almost thought I
was doing myself a favor.
That's when my life really,
really spiraled downhill.
We kept chasing that high.
- [Interviewer] Hold on one second.
Those trucks are so loud.
I'm sorry, say that again.
- Yeah, like I was saying,
that's when my life
really spiraled downhill.
That's when I really
started chasing this high.
And that affordable drug,
no longer became affordable.
When you start stealing
from your mommas purse,
start stealing from your loved ones,
just for a high, is when
it becomes a problem.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- So then you know you got a problem.
And I got a problem.
- [Interviewer] So how
many years has it been
that you've been using heroin now?
- I'm 30-years-old,
started heroin when I was about 26.
It's about the fourth year, maybe even 25,
probably about four to
five years on heroin.
I been popping opiates,
taking opiates since I was about 17.
It's no shit.
I'ma say 16, that when I
was really, really popping.
But playing with them, 14.
Playing with them at 14.
Wasn't addicted, wasn't a problem.
(mumbles) it became a problem
about 16, 17 years old.
That's when it became a problem.
And I was popping those
pills every goddamn day
til I was about 25.
And when I encountered that heroin
that's when life really began for me--
- [Interviewer] So, what does
your heroin addiction cost you now?
- Heroin addiction cost me
damn near my life a few time.
I got heart failure.
I got chronic kidney failure.
I'm prone to abscesses.
- [Interviewer] Oh Jesus.
- And that's how dirty
this drug gets, you know--
- [Interviewer] So that from an abscess?
- It's from an abscess.
An abscess comes from--
- [Interviewer] Abscess is from dirty ...
- It comes--
- [Interviewer] Heroin?
- from a lot of things.
It could come from dirty needles.
In my case, mines come
from the dope is not clean.
- [Interviewer] The dope's not?
- Yeah, one thing I do--
- [Interviewer] It's been
cut with something, or?
- It's the cut, there's
something in that dope
that my body just don't accept.
- [Interviewer] How long
have you had this wound?
- Shit man, this started towards
somewhere in the beginning
stages of me taking heroin,
and I been having this every since.
- [Interviewer] So this is
you've had this for a few years?
- I been having this for a while.
- [Interviewer] It's an open cut.
- On and off. It never
ever completely healed.
I tell you that.
It never ever completely healed.
And actually to tell you the truth, man,
this is looking better than
it actually ever did look really.
As you can tell, man,
this thing was here, to here.
So I'm about more than half the size of--
- [Interviewer] That's
starting to close up.
- what it used to.
It starting to close finally.
But if I don't stop doing what I'm doing,
I'm gonna lose this arm.
I been threatened.
I been threatened multiple times.
- [Interviewer] And
you're living on Skid Row?
- By choice, I don't have to.
- [Interviewer] In a tent?
- Sometimes.
I do have a ...
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I mean it's a filthy--
- I do have a ... yes.
- [Interviewer] It's a filthy lifestyle.
- (murmurs) It's nothing that
you never want to do, but ...
- [Interviewer] Has this got infected?
- Having this drug you will do anything
to stay close by to it.
Like I said, dope sick is
something that you try to prevent.
And in order for you not
to be dope sick, man,
you got to be high.
You got to have that drug in.
And that's what caused
me to stay on Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] As you said earlier,
you'd rather die than ...
- Than be sick.
- [Interviewer] Than be dope sick.
- Yes sir.
- [Interviewer] That give the viewers
a little bit of a (laughs) idea
of how difficult it is to get off a drug.
- I'm still on it.
In fact, I shot before this video.
And I might shoot after this.
- [Interviewer] How many
times a day do you fix?
- Seven, eight.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I'm shooting about two
to three grams a day.
- [Interviewer] And what
are you doing for money?
- Anything, cut hair, to stealing,
to robbing, to anything.
I ain't gonna say anything
'cause (laughs) there's things I done
that, you know,
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(laughs) you just won't do.
- You know I'm not finna go there
You guys know what I'm talking about.
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
- I won't go there. (laughs)
but yeah, I do go far enough.
- [Interviewer] You've
had medical attention
for this of course?
- Absolutely.
Actually ...
- [Interviewer] You just
came from the hospital?
- Just came from the hospital.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
They didn't wrap it up, bandage it?
- I took it off.
- [Interviewer] Oh you took it off?
- Why? To shoot dope.
- [Interviewer] Oh, did you
shoot it right into that?
Wow.
- It's something that y'all
don't want to do, man.
Take this, you got to
take this for (murmurs).
This ain't it, this ain't it.
I never thought I would be here.
I never thought that.
I never thought that
I would be doing this.
You know, I come from a
a loving, caring family.
I'm hurting them, you know,
I'm hurting them.
They loved me dearly.
They haven't even let me go yet.
- [Interviewer] They know
you're in this situation?
- They know I'm in a situation.
They trying to help.
But it's up to me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
No one can do it for you.
- Do I want help?
I do want help.
I do want to stop.
But this demon, man, it's a demon.
And it's by far one of
the hardest things I ever encountered.
The hardest battle I
ever, ever fought, man.
That I'm still fighting right now
and it's winning. It's winning.
It's getting the best of me.
But I pray that one day I win.
- [Interviewer] I wish
you the best of luck, man.
- I'll be successful.
- [Interviewer] Thank you so much, Kevin.
- Thank you.